allons-y bonjour messieurs dames
euh Jérôme Durin je suis président de la
commission d'enquête sur le narcotrafic
je suis accompagné deétienne blanc et de
collègues élus des administrateurs qui
travaillent avec nous sur ce sujet nous
vous remercions de votre présence à
cette audition aujourd'hui je vais
commencer par une dimension formelle
puisque une prestation de serment est
exigée des personnes qui participent aux
audit donc je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévu aux articles 434-13 434-14 et
434-1 du code pénal et donc je vais vous
inviter chacune et chacun d'entre vous
successivement à prêter serement de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité à
lever la main droite et à dire je le
jure madame peut-être commencer
oui bonjour à tous
je je jure de dire toute la vérité merci
Madame le Commissaire euh
messieurs je le jure je le jure je le
jure merci pour cette dimension formelle
alors ce que je vous propose peut-être
c'est que vous commenciez par une un
propos liminaire et puis on passe
ensuite à l'exercice des questions et
Ronse ça vous va il reste juste à
choisir qui
commence les messieurs d'un côté ou
madame de l'autre comme vous voulez
bonjour alors pour la Martinique alors
sans sans je suis désolé pour pour
Camille peut-être démarrer avec
effectivement un état de la menace
global sur la sur la zone Caraïbes qui
pourra être
complété par donc les collègues de la
gendarmerie et de la douane pour ensuite
resserer le le focus sur le territoire
de de Guadeloupe si ça va à chacun ça ça
nous va parfaitement on vous demandera
juste de vous présenter avant
d'intervenir pour qu'on sache qui est
qui
merci bien évidemment bonjour monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Rapporteur mes
Mesdames et Messieurs les les sénateurs
Alexandre gu je suis commissaire
divisionnaire chef de l'antenne auast
Caraïb basé en
Martinique g directeur
interrégional pour la
douane général William vet commandant la
gendarmerie de
Martinique
merci et et comme
équ pardon commissaire de police chef du
service territorial de police judiciaire
de
Guadeloupe merci Madame et ben allez-y
on vous laisse
commencer merci bien euh donc je crois
que voilà certaines auditions déjà
réalisées je pense à celle de Monsieur
le DGPN de Madame la chef de l'oface ou
encore du responsable du SGM ont déjà pu
vous donner une vision claire et lucide
du narcotrafic de ces défis et de
certaines perspectives pour nous
aujourd'hui il pourrait être question de
compléter ce tour d'horizon avec un
focus plus plus particulier sur la zone
antiaise marquée bien évidemment par le
trafic maritime ce focus n'est pas dénué
de sens lorsqu'on se rappelle qu'en 2022
75 % des saisis de cocaïne à savoir plus
de 27 tonnes l'ont été sur des vecteurs
maritimes et que 55 % des saisis de
cocaïne proviennent des Antilles et de
laaguyan alors sans effectuer de de
mauvaise paraphrases d'é lsé reclus j'ai
envie de dire que la géographie précède
l'histoire ce qui est lié avec notre
sujet du jour puisqueen effet les îles
françaises aux Antilles sont dans le
dispositif avec la Guan bien sûr les
territoires les plus proches des zones
de production de cocaïne nulle surprise
ainsi à ce que les liens anciens et
puissent développer et que la Martinique
et la Guadeloupe notamment constituent
depuis longtemps des zones de rebond et
de transit nulle surprise non plus dès
lors que l'Office central en charge de
la lutte contre le trafic de stupéfiants
et depuis le le début des années 2000
installé une antenne en Martinique un
dispositif ultérieurement complétés avec
les détachements au fastes de Guadeloupe
dont vous avez une représentante euh et
la chef et de Saint-Martin également
alors pour structurer mon mon propos je
brosserai tout d'abord un état de la
menace sur sur la zone avant d'évoquer
le dispositif en place et enfin quelques
pistes et perspectives avant bien sûr de
laisser la la parole du à mes collègues
de la Douine et de la gendarmerie pour
largement compléter ajouter et et
préciser sur l'état de la menace alors
mon exposé concernera principalement la
cocaïne mais je seraai ponctuellement
amené à évoquer également d'autres
produits alors c'est un chiffre qui vous
a déjà été fourni mais donc pour rappel
la production de de cocaïne qui a été
évaluée en 2021 à 2300 tonnes concentré
en Colombie Pérou Bolivie elle s'étend
de plus au Honduras et au Guatemala
alors la la cocaïne dont le prix aussi
alors entre 1000 et 1500 dollars le
kilgram va prendre plusieurs routes ça
peut être des routes aériennes ou
fluviales vers l'est vers l'iguyane ou
le Brésil mais aussi pour ce qui va plus
directement donc impacter les Antilles
vers le nord jusqu'au côtes caribéenne
de la Colombie et des
Venezuela cette cocaïne va ensuite être
chargée transbordée parfois plusieurs
reprises pour trouver sa place sur
divers vecteurs maritimes ça peut être
par exemple des puissantes landchasse
comme on dit des des piroges de de pêche
à moteur ou des tapouilles des bureau de
pêche à forte capacité d'emport ces
bateaux ont plusieurs destinations
potentielles route centrale à travers la
la Caraïbes peut les mener vers la
République Dominicaine ou vers Porto
Rico voir les îles Vierges avec infin
comme destination le marché américain
mais on a bien sûr aussi une route plus
orientale directement vers les îles des
Petites Antilles ou alors en longeant
les côtes vénézuéliennes puis celle de
trinid Tobago avant de remonter
l'arcantillet et c'est ce qui va nous
impacter plus plus directement puisquen
effet ces bateaux qu'on appelle bateau m
vont alors se mettre au contact de
bateau filles qui vont récupérer le le
produit stupéfiant la cocaïne dont le
transbordement sera régulièrement
accompagné de son garde du corps j'ai
envie de dire souvent armé qui qui peut
être chargé de surveiller son bon
acheminement à toutes les étapes euh
étape suivante c'est batopi alors ça
peut être des yoles de pêche des
caboteurs des voiliers euh on constate
j'allais dire au gré des interceptions
réalisées par les uns et les autres que
presque finalement tout tout ce qui
flotte peut peut servir et être utilisé
euh ces vecteurs vont ensuite
transporter la cocaïne jusqu'aux rivages
et plages des îles françaises soit
directement ou alors avec un premier
stop chez nos îles voisines la Dominique
ou saint lucide pour évoquer les plus
proche dans ce deuxème cas on est là
déjà en présence d'un premier rebond qui
va ensuite expliquer l'intensité du
traffic Inter qui se déroule dans les
divers
canons une fois parvenue en Guadeloupe
en Martinique la cocaïne dont le prix
est alors là de 5500 à 6000 € le le kilo
va être stocké avant d'être ventilé
alors ventilé elle va l'être de
différentes manières elle peut l'être
dans des quantités alors plus limitées
pour alimenter le le marché local
notamment via les PDD euh il faut pas
oublier voilà qu'on a ce ce marché local
de cocaïne alors soit cocaïne qui va
rester sous cet état ou alors des
laarbau de craque aussi avec cette
transformation notamment dans certains
secteurs concentrés sur fort- de France
ou le le lamenttin le marché local ici
donc en plus de la cocaïne et également
la destination finale d'herbe de
cannabis puisqu'on a une herbe de
cannabis qui est produite régionalement
aussi euh qui va être transporté souvent
par les mêmes vecteurs maritimes avec
parfois également des des armes des
migrants donc on a bien aussi un marché
local à la fois d'Herb de cannabis et de
cocaïne néanmoins pour la plus grande
partie cette cocaïne après
reconditionnement va être réexpédié vers
l'Europe et plus spécifiquement vers la
France hexagonale alors là selon
diverses modalités que vous connaissez
la première celle du container profitant
je dirais des liaisons maritimes avec
les rotations régulières qui relient les
ports de Jarry en Guadeloupe et celui de
de Fort de France au port du nord de
l'Europe c'est cette modalité qui permet
effectivement d'acheminer les quantités
les plus importantes comme en témoigne
régulièrement les saisis opérés à la
fois au AV à der mais également dans
d'autres ports comme ceux de Montoir de
Bretagne ou même rouand ce qui fait
suite à la à la ce qui fait suite pardon
à un travail douignier auou policier qui
est effectué en métropole mais qui peut
également être le le fruit de
renseignement du travail effectué ici
aux Antilles on peut évoquer diverses
méthodes le la première le le rip enfin
qui est la plus utilisée avec une
dissimulation de la cocï dans des
cargaisons de divers produits notamment
également de de déchets métalliques
puisque c'est un type de cargaison qui
par fréquemment dans des quantités
importantes des Antilles jusqu'à la
métropole pour le retraitement on peut
avoir aussi la méthode des faux
déménagement ou encore la création de
société légale dont les expéditions vont
servir de couverture finalement aux
cargaison de de
cocaïne parvenu donc dans l'Hexagone là
la cocaïne va se négocier autour de 30
30000 € le le
kil euh quelques mots sur une autre
modalité de réexpédition du coup de la
de la cocaïne la les mules
aéroportuaires alors là c'est vrai qu'on
n'est pas je dirais en présence des
mêmes flux qu'en guyan certes mais la
Guadeloupe comme la Martinique ne manque
pas malheureusement de candidat au au
voyage dont les vulnérabilités jeallis
dire vont être exploité par différents
réseaux pour inciter et parfois même
forcer au au voyage au transport de
cocaïne que cette cocaïne soit spotcher
à cor transportter dans des valises
voire insérer ou encore ingéré euh
s'agissant des mules deux remarques une
première qui tient au lien à la Guyane
puisqu'on constate que les territoires
de la Guadeloupe et de la Martinique ont
servi et servent encore régulièrement
j'allais dire de de passage de transit
pour certains réseaux qui souhaitent
contourner les contrôles 100 % et les
ciblages directs des vols directs
justement entre Cayenne et les aéroports
parisiens c'est le cas notamment euh ces
derniers temps on peut signaler des
raisons N nigérien qui de plus en plus
envoie également directement à partir de
Paris des individus des ressortissants
nigériens mais qui sont en possession de
passeport espagnol italien ou allemand
qui vont être envoyés directement de
Paris vers la Guadeloupe ou la
Martinique on a aussi ces liens ces
liens directs deuxième remarque on a des
mules en résine de cannabis également
puisque la résine ce produit n'est pas
régionalement il va être importé à
partir de la métropole jusqu'aux anti
pour être vendu là aussi selon
différentes modalités les PDD au côté de
l'herbe de cannabis et de la la cocaïne
alors la résine ce type de produit peut
également être acheminé aux Antilles
selon d'autres modalités euh container
expédition de véhicules ce sont des
choses également qu'on qu'on trouve à
des équipes ici qui dans l'autre sens
elles vont faire parvenir leurs
partenaires hexagonaux de la COP on a
voilà un cl en cours qui nous caisine
avec laasr euh j'évoquerai rapidement
donc les navires de plaisance c'est voyé
puisque là aussi c'est une modalité
utilisée c'est type de vecteur qui est
utilisé pour faire parvenir la cocaïne
jusqu'aux côtes européennes là on est en
présence de
réseau régulièrement je dirais animés
par des criminels étrangers originaire
d'Europe du Nord ou d'Europe de l'Est
ces réseaux qui vont recourir à des
équipages pour des convvoyages qui vont
s'appuyer sur une logique là aussi qui
est souvent en lien avec avec l'Espagne
des bases logistiques des skippers euh
et qui portent là sur des quantités là
aussi assez importantes ces voyers vont
ensuite être donc chargé dans la zone
Caraïbe ou alors encore au large du
plateau des desiguillan avant d'entamer
soit une route transatlantique directe
soit de remonter vers le nord euh
l'arcantillet avant de traverser ça va
être fonction des conditions climatiques
trouvé par les par les réseaux mais
aussi de la présence alors connue ou
supposée de moyens d'intervention à la
mer une remarque complémentaire comme en
métropole les trafic de supéfiant vont
de pair avec
desexercice de de diverses violences euh
on est aujourd'hui à 25 homicides
volontaires sur la sur l' Martinique euh
alors on a voilà des homicides des
tentatives d'homicide volontairees qui
peuvent être motivés par des rivalités
ou des différences sur fond de trafic de
stupéfiants pas toujours d'ailleurs de
de très haut niveau euh d'ailleurs on a
par contre également régulièrement
l'écho euh de l'existence de Hitmen hein
donc de je dire de de de tueurs
notamment d'origine saint-lucienne qui
peuvent être recrutés afin d'exécuter
des contrats euh parfois jusque sur le
sol
Martinique ces violences euh peuvent
être quant à elle facilité par
l'importante circulation des armes à feu
ces dernières qui peuvent être soit
destinées à protéger le trafic de
stupéfiants les différents intervenants
ou alors qui peuvent également
constituer une cargaison à part entière
en elle-même qui va être acheminée en
guadeloup ou en Martinique notamment à
partir de saintouci euh qui elle les
reçoit des États-Unis
principalement au moins autant qu'en
qu'en métropole hein et c'est c'est une
une tendance qui vous a été évoquée par
le DGPN et puis par Madame chbonier le
le le risque de voir finir sa vie de
manière prématurée lors d'un épisode de
confrontation violente lié au trafic de
toute nature d'ailleurs est totalement
intégré ici par les trafiquants sur sur
la zone alors deème point par face à cet
état de la menace un rapide état du
dispositif alors s'agissant de l'auface
Caraïbe on a donc trois entités qui sont
basées en Martinique en Guadeloupe et à
Saint-Martin qui font partie des 24
antennes et détachements de l'offast
afin comme d'autres administrations
partenaires de mailler le mieux possible
l'arc
l'arcantier au plan régional donc
l'offaste Caraïbe la composition
interadministration et même
internationale puisque nous avons la
présence d'un officier liaison espagnol
dans nos murs je assure les les mêmes
missions que l'ofaste au niveau central
tel qu'elles ont pu vous être exposé par
Stéphanie chirbonier en s'inscrivant
dans le plan national stupéfiant pour
les reprendre rapidement donc sur le
volet stratégie et là aussi
établissement d'un d'un état de la
menace régionale l'analyse des flux et
phénomènes constaté sur le sur le bassin
entier euh tout ce qui est étude sur le
prix des des stupéfiants mais également
définition et actualisation de façon
concertée avec nos partenaires des ces
d'intérêt prioritaires à l'échelle
caribéenne sur le volet renseignement
bien sûr le dispositif des des cross qui
existe les trois territoires pardon pour
le recueil l'analyse l'enrichissement le
partage du renseignement supervision de
de carof Fast et des PDD sur tous les
segments donc voilà de ce qui est
effectivement géré au niveau des PDD
jusque dans les trafics internationaux
en lien avec la métropole je
mentionnerai aussi un dispositif
particulier qui est celui de l'Unité
permanente de renseignement Caraïb qui
permet la projection régulière à Saint
lucide d'enquêteurs français
spécifiquement en matière de
renseignement dans le domaine des
stupéfiants des jalons ont été récemment
lancés dans ce sens également avec l'île
de la Dominique enfin donc troisème
mission qui concerne plus directement le
volet opérationnel avec là l'existence
de plusur plusieurs pardon groupes
opérationnels spécialisés chargés des
enquêtes judiciaires que ce soit en
Martinique en Guadeloupe ou à
Saint-Martin puisque effectivement une
des plusvalue de l'offast j'all dire
au-delà des saisies opérées qu'elle soit
d'initiative par l'offast ou encore
après des interceptions maritimes
réalisées par la Marine nationale la
douane ou la gendarmerie avec leurs
moyens en mer la plusvalueas c'est de
parvenir j'irais au démantelllement
complet du réseau l'identification des
commanditaires récomplisses pour
démanteler ce réseau le privé de de ces
moyens sources et profits générés alors
ce sont des missions qui sont assurées
c'est important de le mentionner très
régulièrement en caisine avec d'autres
entités au fast mais aussi le GIR des
sections de recherche ou le service
d'enquête judiciaire fiscal également en
lien avec les agences partenaaires qui
sont présentes sur la zone mais
également nos correspondants des î état
voisines et enfin avec les attachés de
sécurité intérieur ou officiers de
liaison sur la zone notamment en
Colombie et au vénézuel
euh pour ne pas être trop long euh
simplement quelques points d'attention
et quelques perspectives alors sans être
là forcément original justement par
rapport à des choses qui ont déjà pu
vous être avancé lors de précédentes
interventions l'importance du
développement de la surveillance
périmétrique de l'île en complément des
moyens existants des projets existent
relatif à l'usage de de drone ou
développement de de radar maritime c'est
en cours de de développement
actuellement des avancées en cours
également qui vise à développer la
sécurisation des installations
portuaires et dans le domaine du
contrôle des des containers et c'est
bien sûr aussi d' d'un œil attentif que
nous suivons les travaux destinés à
renforcer tout ce qui est autorisation
d'accès permanente aux installations
portuaires par rapport au au personnel
dokerer et et autres euh
j'insisteraiis sur le thème de de la
corruption aussi qui est une thématique
forte sur la zone et qui est vraiment à
prendre en compte même lors dans le
développement de nos concrètement de de
nos partenariats et la nécessaire
agilité que nous avons développé pour
être toujours celle enfin au niveau
pardon de celle des trafiquants alors
qu'on constate que certains phénomènes
se développent et sont peut-être amenés
à
s'intensifier celui du du dropof par
exemple mais également le transport le
transport pardon sous une forme non
aboutie de la cocaïne mais qui
nécessitera une transformation avec
l'existence de de laboratoires qui
pourront être utilisés euh et localisés
en en
Europe le renforcement de la coopération
internationale est aussi un point
important euh je je l'ai abordé mais
sans doute que ma collègue de degadou
qui reviendra également par rapport à la
à la Dominique
euh les défis voilà ils sont aussi
technologiques toujours la nécessaire
veille développement technologique en
plus de la formation associée euh sur
tout ce qui est application de
communication crypté qui sont là aussi
largement partagés et utilisés euh mais
également sur tout ce qui est
possibilité blanchiment via des des
cryptoactifs
euh au niveau de la saisie des avoirs
c'est aussi un domaine dans lequel on
peut progresser peut-être en cherchant
quelques pistes aussi parfois pour
simplifier ou accélérer certains
certains processus euh s'agissant enfin
spécifiquement des des Entilles euh on
pourrait aussi peut-être alors revoir le
la liste de tout ce qui est marchandis
soumis à l' 3 de mer pour essayer d'en
d'en exonérer plus largement certains
équipements qui sont parfois destiné aux
forces de de sécurité intérieure sur le
ressort voilà pour cette présentation
globale de de l'état de la menace que
nous pourrons bien sûr compléter au gré
des questions mais également des des
ajouts fait
Parè
merci
vous parliez pour le compte de vous
trois et puis on je pose des questions
on posera les questions à tout le monde
en même temps et on laisse peut-être
Madame la Commissaire de Police
intervenir et puis ensuite on fait un un
un round de de de questions ça vous va
c'est très bien
reçu parfait pour moi alors pour vous
présenter les entités en fait qui
luttent contre le le narcotrafic en
Guadeloupe donc on a une uses donc qui
est une unité de lutte contre les
trafics de stupéfiants et de l'économie
souterraine qui est composée de six
effectifs et qui travaille donc à une
échelle locale notamment sur les
démantellements de point de ville et on
a comme le disait le Commissaire
Alexandre gu deux détachements au fast
donc l'un basé en Guadeloupe qui est
composé de 19 effectifs et l'autre à
Saint-Martin composé de H effectifs et
qui donc travaillent sur la lutte contre
les trafics internationaux de
stupéfiants et également à l'échelle
régionale pour vous donner un exemple de
notre activité pour notre bilan 2022 on
a pu participer à la saisie de 2 tonnes
d' de cocaïne donc principalement dans
des dossiers de conten en lien avec les
les douanes métropolitaines de 638 kg de
cannabis et nous avons placé en garde à
vue 164 individus pour des pour des des
des dossiers de de trafic de stupéfiants
et sur ces 164 100 ont été écroués donc
ont été placés en détention un point qui
est très important pour nous c'est la
saisie des avoirs criminels sur chaque
dossier d'envergure de narcotrafic on
associe le GIR donc on a un GIR en
Guadeloupe et également il se déplace à
Saint-Martin et sur l'année dernière on
a pu saisir 1,2 million d'euros dans des
dossiers de narcotrafic dont 800000 € en
liquide dans un seul dossier chez un
narcotrafiquant on a pu également saisir
quatre bateaux et 15
véhicules on saisit également
régulièrement des armes dans nos dossier
de narcotrafic sur l'année 2022 on a
saisi 23 armes donc ce sont
principalement des armes de point des
Taurus des glogs des Smith et Wesson euh
et en 2023 on est déjà à 40 saisis
d'armes sur les dossiers de narcotrafic
donc en très forte augmentation ce n'est
d'ailleurs pas lié uniquement au
narcotrafic mais à la Guadeloupe et même
aux Antilles de manière générale où en
fait on a une très forte circulation des
armes à feu sur le territoire on a un
taux d'omicide qui est 7 fois supérieur
à la moyenne nationale sur l'année 2023
on décompte en zone police nationale 16
homicides on en a eu 17 l'année dernière
et donc c'est un point sur lequel on est
très vigilant à la fois pour la sécurité
de nos policiers lors des
interpellations dans les dossiers de
narcotrafic mais aussi les autres les
vols à armé les homicides tentatives
d'homicide et euh cette forte présence
des armes euh est donc révélatrice de de
de la très importante circulation des
armes sur le le territoire
guadeloupéen sur les problématiques que
rencontre le service territorial de
polisjudiciaire en Guadeloupe j'en
citerai deux principales euh une qui a
déjà a été évoqué d'ailleurs par le le
commissaire divisionnaire c'est la
problématique des mules en 2022 on a
traité 35 procédures de mules à 95 %
c'était des des mules qui avaient de la
cocaïne dans les valises ou scotcher sur
le corps en 2023 on est déjà à 48 mules
et en très très grande majorité ce sont
des mules incorporées qui ont donc
ingérer des boulettes de cocaïne c'est
effectivement à peu près au même moment
que
le début des contrôles systématiques en
Guyane alors il y a une double
problématique ce sont à la fois des
mules qui effectivement transit par les
Antilles en et qui arrivent de Guyane et
donc qui partent ensuite par la
métropole mais on s'est aperçu qu'il y
avait également des filières
d'approvisionnement local des mules
c'est chronophage pour nous à la fois
parce que ce sont des des procédure en
flagrant d' qu'il faut traiter mais il
faut également qu'on travaille de
manière parallèle sur ces filières
d'acheminement
euh c'est également chronophage pour les
services de voie publique de la police
nationale il n'y a pas que le judiciaire
même si c'est mon
service puisqu'il faut garder cellules
parfois 6 à 10 jours pour l'expulsion
donc des boulettes de cocaïne donc ça
impacte la présence voie publique
puisque les effectifs sont à l'hôpital
pour garder les mules on a eu d'ailleurs
deux overdoses de mules cette année en
Guadeloupe ce qui est quand même
conséquent il n en avait eu il n en
avait pas eu en
2022 ça oblige les services publics de
manière générale à se bah à se réunir
sur cette problématique ce qu'on a pu
faire d'ailleurs avec le tribunal
judiciaire et les
douanes mais également avec l'hôpital
pour qui c'est aussi une problématique
nouvelle à gérer une autre problématique
c'est euh la situation géographique de
la Guadeloupe dans les Caraïbes qui est
une plaque donc tournant du trafic de
cocaïne on a eu dernièrement des
dossiers d'ampleur en terme de trafic de
cocaïne ou des Colombiens des
venezuélien ont été mis en cause et qui
faisait donc transiter la cocaïne par la
Guadeloupe on peut effectivement parler
aussi de la de la première mission de
l'Unité permanente de renseignement de
l'OFAS qui s'est déplacée à la Dominique
la semaine dernière et qui nous permet
d'avancer considérablement sur ce sujet
en terme de coopération
sachant que pour la Guadeloupe la
dernière île rebond pour l'arrivée des
armes des stupéfiants et des étrangers
en situation irrégulière sur le
territoire c'est la Dominique donc avec
effectivement souvent des armes qui
proviennent des États-Unis et qui font
des rebonds sur les différentes îles de
la Caraïbe jusqu'à la Dominique et après
arrivver en Guadeloupe via parfois Marie
Galante les saintes ou tout simplement
le littoral
guadeloupéen en piste d'amélioration sur
lesqueles on travaille déjà et il faut
aussi qu'on qu'on puisse se renforcer
c'est bien évidemment moyen humain et
matériel puisque je l'ai dit le
traitement des mules est très
chronophage et on doit pouvoir garder
une capacité opérationnelle de
traitement judiciaire des
filières on continue notre travail de
partenariat avec les services de douane
avec la justice avec ce projet aussi
donc du Pr à la Dominique on a créé
récemment et mis en place récemment une
cross permanente en Guadeloupe et une
cross non permanente à Saint-Martin ce
qui permet effectivement de de mieux
collecter et d'enrichir les informations
sur le sur les narcotrafic euh pour les
douanes les la gendarmerie nationale et
la police nationale et une plusvalue
aussi en terme de lutte contre le
narcotrafic ça a été la réalisation d'un
pilotage intégré sur ce domaine
notamment grâce à la création des
directions territoriales de la police
nationale puisquon est dtpn depuis 2 ans
en Guadeloupe presque 2 ans euh et on
organise tous les semestres des réunions
avec tous les acteurs de la police
nationale avec la police aux frontières
avec le renseignement territorial avec
l'état-major avec la formation où on se
coordonne ensemble pour être plus
efficace sur sur cette problématique un
exemple on s'aperçoit que dans un des
dossiers de l'ofast euh il y a un sujet
sur un aérodrome euh on n pas vraiment
d'éléments précis en terme d'enquête et
bien on peut demander à la police aux
frontières d'accentuer les contrôles sur
cet aérodrome afin de déterminer ce qui
se passe réellement donc c'est une vraie
plusvalu de pouvoir échanger tous
ensemble
euh sur le le domaine du
narcotrafic merci Madame la Commissaire
je vais laisser notre rapporteur Étienne
blanc compléter ces information par les
questions merci Madame la Commissaire
vous avez parlé de suggestion
d'amélioration est-ce que dans ces
suggestions vous avez envisagé des
mesures
législatives première question et
deuxème question si j'ai bien compris le
traitement des mules à l'hôpital c'est
quelque chose qui est à la fois
chronophage qui mobilise vos services
les problèmes de gestion du temps et
cetera est-ce que sur ce sujet
particulier vous avez des propositions
de simplification pour augmenter le
contrôle des
mules alors sur la la problématique é
mul euh en fait pour l'instant on est on
est surtout impacté en fait c'est le
début de de l'impact de ce phénomène
donc on est déjà en train de voilà de
voir toute l'ampleur et et et tout ce
que ça nécessite en terme de moyens
engagés euh on est en train de repenser
donc ça c'est alors pas pas au niveau de
de la police judiciaire mais au niveau
de l'étatmajor de la direction
territoriale de la police nationale
notre convention avec l'hôpital pour
mieux prendre en compte cette cette
problématique et surtout limiter le
temps euh d'attente des effectifs de
voie publique euh qui euh qui attendent
en fait devant la chambre de la Mle pour
pour la garder euh on a également des
réunions avec avec Madame la procureure
que vous verrez tout à l'heure et les
douanes pour de manière identique
améliorer la prise en charge des mules
entre le traitement des douanes au début
et puis nous qui reprenons donc en
judiciaire derrière euh et ensuite pour
le volet euh le volet judiciaire une
fois que la mule est présenté
euh donc on est actuellement en train de
de travailler sur ces différents
protocoles pour pour s'améliorer et pour
limiter le temps que que ça occasionne
en terme de voilà de traitement
d'enquête et d'attente à l'hôpital en
terme d'évolution législative alors je
laisserai peut-être Alexandre Huget s'il
a des pistes là-dessus répondre de mon
côté j'en ai pas
particulièrement
parole peut-être alors nous sommes
accompagnés de de quelques collègues qui
grelotent avec nous dans une salle trop
froide euh mais peut-être certains
d'entre eux ont-ils des questions à
poser je signale que notre collègue
Catherine Conconne ne pouvait être avec
nous qu'elle souhaitait vous passer le
bonjour pour ceux d'entre vous qui la
connaissent qui veut se lancer monsieur
le rapporteur pardonnez-moi je je
souhaiteraiis général va je souhaiterais
intervenir sur les les évolutions
juridiques euh fait général fait
voilà donc très rapidement euh dans
l'espace caribéen les entrées les
sorties sur les territoires donc là je
me place pas sur le terrain de
l'investigation mais sur le terrain du
contrôle du terrain
c'est-à-dire de couper la route et de
mieux contrôler la Pise amélioration de
mieux contrôler les entrées et sorties
tout autour de nous on est dans un
espace on est plutôt un département
français d'Amérique géographiquement
tout autour de nous il y a des
déclarations préalable à l'entrée
c'està-dire euh c'est un peu le l'ESTIA
américain qu'on n pas ici parce qu'on n
pas dans dans un espace
et par exemple si on va sainuci il faut
déclarer avant c'est pas un visa mais
c'est une déclaration près de l'entrée
qui permet déjà d'avoir un climage des
gens qui vont venir vont partir et
surtout où est-ce qu'ils vont loger donc
ça renforce ce contrôle il me semble
qu'il y a une difficulté juridique avec
l'Union européenne je ne sais pas si ça
relève du législatif ou du réglementaire
mais il y a matière à réfléchir à
pouvoir renforcer notre contrôle des
flux entrées et sorties des des
personnes avec le dispositif esa de tous
nos voisins moi quand je vais en
République Dominicaine je remplis un
eTicket quand je vais à saint-usi je
fais une déclaration préalable et il me
s que il me semble que c'est une piste
de de
réflexion pour aller dans le sens Gali
douan euh de ce que vient de dire le le
général alors il y a un sujet qui est en
train d'être réglé et c'est celui de la
cirance c'est-à-dire tout ce qui va
concerner les voiliers qui circulent
entre les différentes îles de de
l'espace caribéen puisque le préfet de
de Martinique en tant que délégué à
l'action de l'État en mer a pris un
arrêté au mois de
juillet 2023 qui rend obligatoire ce
système le clirance qui existe dans les
autres les autres îles et début de
l'année
2024 la douane qui est qui est leader
sur ce dossier là va mettre en service
un un système informatique de clearance
pour le moderniser et c'est vrai que par
rapport à au système européens comme qui
doit se mettre en place euh notre nos
territoire n'étant pas dans dans
l'espace Schengen euh il y a pas une
déclinaison immédiate ou parallèle de ce
même ce même
système merci alors je crois que marieor
finira hors tout le POS question juste
unot encore pour pour nourrir les
réflexions par rapport à à ce qui a été
extrêmement bien présenté par par nos
collègues policiers une dimension qui
est qui existe aussi dans le transfert
des marchandises c'est l'utilisation du
fret postal du fret du fret express qui
est relativement important puisquon doit
sur la zone faire pour ce qui nous
concerne nous douanes
quasiment voilà 800 800
dossiers relativement importants sur ce
type d'échange qui est quelque chose qui
est quasi quotidien ou même quotidien
euh que ça soit l'arrivée de résine de
cannabis en provenance de l'Hexagone ou
le départ de petite quantité de de
cocaïne encore une fois entre 200 et 800
g mais qui est assez fréquent et qui est
un mode important de de de trafic auelà
de l'aérien auelà du maritime auelà du
du du
compur merci
euh marieelor fin merci président euh
bonjour madame et Messieurs alors j'ai
deux questions j'en ai une pour Monsieur
Gali et une pour Monsieur Hugé alors
Monsieur Gali vous avez certainement
constater que qu'il y a depuis près d'un
an un déport des mules vers les Antilles
depuis la mise en en place des contrôles
à 100 % à l'aéroport Félix sboué en
Guyane il y a fort à parier que les
trafiquants sont à la recherche de
nouvelles routes ma question est simple
existe-t-il aujourd'hui un travail en
collaboration entre les services aux
Antilles et la guyan puisque les
douaniers guyanais pourraient le cas
échéant indiquer à leurs collègues des
Antilles les mules potentiells et
Monsieur Hugé la multiplication de
saisies de stupéfiants et de
démantelllement de réseaux tant en
Guadeloupe et et Martinique démontre que
vos
territoires comme le mien d'ailleurs se
trouvent au milieu d'un trafic
international or dans un rapport
d'information publié début juillet mes
collègues sénateurs déploraient la
faiblesse des moyens nautiques et
aériens alloués à la lutte contre le
trafic de stupéfiant les forces de
l'ordre rencontré ont expliqué qu'elle
ne dispose pas de moyen d'assurer la
pleine et totale surveillance
périmétrique de l'île et n'avoir
toujours pas pu installer de radar au
sein de port maritime de fort- de-fance
pour contrôler les cargaisons
pouvez-vous me dire si les choses ont
évolué favorablement depuis ce rapport
et une question pour tous les quatre
mais ça ça vient de moi pour avoir
écouté les auditions des maires puisque
moi j'ai été aussi maire de Cayenne
pendant 10 ans euh je je pose la
question qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
l'opportunité de la création d'une
commission ad hoc composée de la PN la
PM euh la
la l'État bien sûr
euh oh là là
j'aiécrit de ouais voilà douane douane
surtout les maires les maires parce que
les maires se sentent souvent exclus euh
des résultats du dispositif et bon les
maires ont quand même quelque chose à
faire aussi au niveau de des dealers au
niveau des des bah des trafiquants qui
sont dans leur commune et donc je me
posais la question que c'était pas
opportun de créer une commission où tout
le monde pourrait retrouver autour d'une
table hormis le CLSPD ou la
collaboration entre la PN et la PN pour
pouvoir justement éradiquer ce trafic
parce que c'est vraiment un fléau dans
nos dans nos villes merci messieur dame
j'ai une question aussi de de Catherine
Conconne notre collègue sénatrice qui me
dit puisqu'elle nous suit à distance
vouloir poser une question à la douane
s'agissant de de ces moyens à agir de
vos moyens agir en mer de quels outils
disposez-vous sont-ils suffisants et
comment on peut améliorer tout ça et je
crois qu'Olivier cadit qui a une
question c'est justement une qui
complète puisque il nous a été dit
précédemment qu'il y avait qu'une seule
frégate et que lorsqu'elle était
elle était en vue entre la Guadeloupe et
la Dominique Le le trafic s'interrompait
et dès que elle partait hop ça
redémarrait donc je voulais savoir si si
effectivement les moyens que vous
envisagez c'était pour permettre une
surveillance permanente de ce en fait de
ce couloir qui apparemment le plus
utiliser vous avez fait valoir qu'il y
avait SEP fois plus d'omicide que dans
l'Hexagone c'est euh effectivement c'est
euh de cette façon c'est un peu
impressionnant mais j'aimerais savoir
par rapport aux îles environnantes
est-ce que quel est notre taux est-ce
que le ce taux domicide est supérieur
par ou inférieure par rapport aux îles
environnantes pour savoir comment on se
positionne dans l'environnement immédiat
et enfin il y a une réflexion qui a été
fait par un maire précédemment qui
disait que du fait de la euh de la peur
qui commençait à naître de la que les
gens préféraient fermer leur leur
fenêtres pour pas être témoins potentiel
de ce du trafic qui allait passé donc il
y avait une crainte qui était forte et
ils envisageaient le développement
de comment dire le d'armer la police
locale du fait du développement de la
violence alors je voudrais savoir ce que
vous pensez de cette de cette idée et
est-ce que vous pensez que ça ne
pourrait pas en fait plutôt provoquer
une escalade donc là aussi en comp
raison avec ce qui se passe dans les
îles autour merci alors une grosse volée
de
question monsieur le monsieur le
sénateur madame la sénatrice si vous
permettez je vais répondre à à cette
question centrale euh justement sur
j'allais dire la coproduction de
sécurité et bien c'est le projet du
contrat territorial de sécurité de
prévention à laquelle la collectivité
territoriale de Martinique mais
également madame la sénatrice Cancon et
tous les maires nous avons eu en début
d'année 2023 le préfet honoraire Lalan
qui a mené une une mission de 3 mois
nous avons corédigé avec les élus la
police la douane la gendarmerie un
projet de de contrat territorial de
sécurité de prévention dans ce contrat
il y a un certain nombre d'Ax qui
répondent aux autres questions qui sont
posées encore une fois on est parti sur
un début de présentation sur couper la
route de la drogue par de
l'investigation mais l' mort et l'axe
qui a bien été identifié par par le
ministre par le préfet c'est de
renforcer ce contrôle et ce partenariat
avec les forces du territoire c'estàd
les élus dans ce contrat territorial de
sécurité il y a un axe
prioritaire qui s'appelle renforcer la
sécurité périmétrique de la Martinique
et derrièurs tout ça vous allez avoir
effectivement le scanner sur le port
vous allez avoir les radars qui seront
pilotés par les armées vous allez avoir
le renforcement je fais au question sur
nos moyens qui sont vieillissants
concernant la frégate il me semble qu'il
y a une peut-être une confusion avec la
patrouille de le patrouilleur l'agent
maritime qui est stationné en Guadeloupe
nous n'avons pas de patrouilleur de la
gendarmerie maritime en Martinique où
elle vient épisodiquement et surtout
comme elle est très très vieillissante
elle est souvent en réparation ici dans
le contrat territorial il est évoqué et
proposé au ministre donc on attend la
venue je pense début 2024 pour le le
signer avec Monsieur monsieur lechimi
présidant de la collectivité
territoriale c'est de créer peut-être
une brigade de surveillance du littoral
laagerie maritime pour renforcer cette
capacité pourquoi je vous dis ça parce
que soit on a une frégate
hauturière de la Marine nationale qui va
plutôt faire des grosses
interceptions au large dans les EAU
internationales et puis sur les côtes
nous avons une brigade nautique avec un
petit semiriigide euh qui va pas à plus
de de nautiques donc soit on n pas assez
soit on a on a trop et l'enjeu c'est
d'avoir des radars qui vont permettre
d'avoir du renseignement mais derrière
tout ça il faut impérativement des
outils de levée de doute et
d'interception c'est la raison pour
laquelle dans le contrat territorial de
sécurité de prévention il y a des
propositions pour remplacer les les
bateaux vieillissants créer des unités
nouvelles mais surtout introduire de la
surveillance technologique avec des la
vidéo protection sur les points
d'embarquement et de débarquement et
j'insiste bien sur les points
d'embarquement et de débarquement
puisqu'on a l'impression que tout arrive
euh chez nous il y a des choses qui
partent et pour compléter euh la
présentation de de la menace euh on a le
sens on a l'impression que tout monte
mais il y a effectivement des stratégies
de contournement il y a des choses qui
redescendent de la Dominique sur la
Martinique et moi j'exprime un point
d'inquiétude par rapport à la situation
d'Haïti euh avec plus de 600000 armes
qui qui circulent on a énormément de
flux d'étrangers en circulation en
situation irrégulière qui redescendent
en rebond de la Dominique notamment
beaucoup d'Haïtiens et moi je suis
inquiet si effectivement il y a cette
opération de l'ONU en Haïti dans ces
réseaux de convoyage qui sont des
réseaux multicart on fait de la drogue
on fait du lambi on fait de la traite
humaine on fait du cambriolage on fait
plein de choses c'est les mêmes
convoyurs sur les petites quantités du
du quotidien c'estd les petits
revendeurs il faut pas exclure que en
cas de coup de pied dans la fourmilière
en Haïti se glissent dans ces réseaux
des gens des gangs et pour l'instant sur
la menace nous avons pas de gang
identifié en Martinique en revanche on a
un phénomène de turagage de de de gang
de saintusci qui agissent sur notre
territoire pour conclure parce que
j'étis très long le contrat territorial
de sécurité prévention c'est la création
d'un bureau de commandement de l'action
de l'État en mer sous l'autorité du
préfet maritime c'est-à-dire le préfet
Bouvier avec véritablement en permanence
un policier un gendarme un douanier qui
ne soit plus une structure plus ou moins
de de de coordination mais de de
commandement et ça c'est un point fort
du du
CTSP pour pour compléter peut-être
simplement voilà sur sur les moyens qui
existent effectivement aujourd'hui des
moyens maritimes aéromaritime qui qui
existe et qui sont coordonnés justement
au niveau de l'action de de l'État en
mer euh j' dirais pour le meilleur
emploi possible plus efficace en
fonction du type de navire que ces
navires du coup soit dépendre
directement de la Marine nationale mais
aussi des douanes ou de la G
l'action direction de la mer la
direction de la mer effectivement
également c'est un dispositif qui a
vocation être renforcé puisque il est
prévu aussi que par exemple la PAF
puisse à son niveau également être doté
d'un d'un d'un bateau à terme et comme
cela a été s dit un dispositif qui sera
complété par des radars maritimes dont
l'implantation est prévu en en 2025 pour
la une meilleure surveillance des canaux
tant au nord qu' qu'au sud de la de la
Martinique et puis également ça a été
mentionné peut-être que le le C de douan
pour VO la compléter sur ce qui est
équipement scanner au niveau portuaire
il a un point faible c'est la les moyens
aériens je m'excuse il y a les moyens
aériens on a des moyens aériens qui sont
vieillissants on on espère moi par
exemple j'ai un B2 un écureuil B2 qui a
qui a 40 ans qui peut pas être équipé de
de de
caméras à l'occasion de les hc160 vont
arriver en métropole donc en outrem on
devrait avoir des HC 145 donc il y a
aussi le renforcement des moyens aériens
qui est nécessaire et
également on parle beaucoup ça fait
rêver les les drones mais les drones en
surveillance maritime thermique ce sont
pas du tout ce qu'on a au quotidien dans
nos unités actuellement qui sont pas du
tout adaptés aux ambrins au vent une une
autonomie trop donc il y a vraiment un
investissement dans le contrat
territorial également du renforcement
des moyens de contrôler
rien en qui concerne la la Guadeloupe
juste pour compléter on est dans la même
dynamique puisqu'on a
également souhaiter donc avoir être doté
désormais d'une unité nautique c'est un
projet qui est en cours au sein de la
direction fédérale de la police
nationale qui a d'ailleurs été présenté
là récemment au dialogue budgétaire et
RH police nationale donc j'espère que
que bientôt on pourra être doté de cette
unité nautique euh et pour revenir à la
question sur les taux domicides alors
effectivement au sein de la Caraïbes euh
la Martinique et la Guadeloupe sont euh
très bien dotés entre guillemets en
terme de tauxomicide puisque dans
l'ensemble euh des pays euh des îles qui
sont autour de nous les taux domicides
sont très largement supérieur que ce
soit Sainte-Lucie la Dominique sans
parler bien évidemment de Haïti de la de
la République Dominicaine voilà donc
c'est vrai queon a des taux d'omicidees
qui par rapport au reste du territoire
français sont très importants mais par
rapport à à la Caraïbe sont plutôt sont
plutôt
bas à titre d'exemple si je peux
compléter simplement à ce niveau-là
s'agissant de saintelcie on est autour
de 75 homicidees pour une population qui
est deux fois moindre que celle de la de
la martique
Hati
3200 par rapport à à ce qui vient d'ê
évoquer avant de répondre aux deux
questions qui m'ont été
posées sur les moyens aériens
euh la
douane vient de recevoir son hélicoptère
hc160 donc qui est en train d'être mise
en service opérationnel donc ça va
améliorer la couverture et l'état de
surface et et le Beach avion est
également présent euh là où il y a
vraiment euh au regard de la topologie
des lieux qui ont des distance très
courtes entre nos îles voisines euh et
que malgré l'empilement je dirais de en
c'est peut-être pas l'empilement des
moyens euh qui euh qui qui qui donneront
une vraie protection mais c'est vrai que
c'est un état surface permanent donc les
radars qu'on a évoqué vont être un gros
plus pour pouvoir accentuer la la
surveillance périmétrique de la
Martinique et clairement pareil dans
dans le cadre de la em je pense que les
militaires travaillent sur la présence
de drones plus important et qui pourront
rester en l'air et pouvoir assurer cette
surveillance continue je crois que pour
nous tous service service répressif
enquêteur c'est c'est vraiment le point
de départ d'avoir une vision permanente
de ce qui euh peut arriver et qui arrive
par la mer principalement en matière de
stupéfiant pour qu'on puisse avoir cette
bille 24h/ 24 et c'est ça qui nous
permettra avec les nouveaux moyens dont
dont chacun a parlé de pouvoir faire des
interventions plus efficaces qu'elles ne
le sont
aujourd'hui dans la même veine de
l'amélioration des moyens euh l'arrivée
de scanner mobile en boadeloup en
Guillan euh et en Martinique au début au
1er trimestre 2025 va nous permettre et
bien de scanner les conteneurs sur une
sur une plus grande échelle et de rendre
donc le le travail compliqué plus
compliqué pour les les trafiquants de
stupéfiants sur la question concernant
euh madame les sénatrice de guyan euh
sur le les les cellules de ciblage il
existe au sein de de la des directions
des douanes dans les brigades d'aéroport
des cellules de
ciblage il est bien évident que elles
sont en
relation mais elles sont en relation pas
simplement
entre guyan Martinique Guadeloupe mais
également avec nos collègues d'arrivée
de de de roiss ou
d'orli important c'est au-delà du du du
renseignement opérationnel qui peut être
transmis c'est aussi un renseignement
tactique que je vais qualifier comme ça
de pouvoir dire ben voilà des cellules
de ciblage ça reste à dimension humaine
on a à peu près entre 6 et agents donc
il y a les périodes où il y a un certain
nombre de vols c'est difficile de les
faire je dirais de manière complète par
contre d'utiliser le temps de transport
entre guillemets sur les vols
transatlantiques ou même sur les les 2
heures entre la guillane et la
Martinique permet dire bah voilà on a
peut-être à la cellule de départ pas
beaucoup travaillé ce vol donc il est
plus intéressant à contrôler à l'arrivée
où on l'a très bien travaillé et on peut
mettre à l'arrivée notre notre activité
sur d'autres d'autres vol et donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment en
train de se structurer de manière forte
c'est la même chose avec les conteneurs
où l'arrivée des scanners va nous amener
à développer sur la guadou Martinique et
la Guyane des cellules de des cellules
de ciblage conteneur en relation avec le
Havre avec Marseille avec der qui sont
les entre les points de de départ et
d'arrivé encore une fois pour
insécuriser au maximum le le trafic et
les trafiquants dans leur activités
oui merci euh de ces informations très
très complète une question
complémentaire et quand eu des masses
financières qui circulent
est-ce que vous avez constaté des
dérapages et des dérives dans le domaine
de la corruption au sein de vos services
ou de manière générale dans les
collectivités territoriales dans les
administrations est-ce que pour vous
cela constitue un risque est-ce que vous
avez mis en place des dispositifs de
prévention et si vous avez constaté
quels sont les moyens que vous avez mis
en place pour lutter contre cette
corruption si si vous permettez euh
voilà je crois que en tant que
représentant d'administration des
douanes donc on est les capteurs je
dirais de de premier niveau du contrôle
du quotidien il est bien évident qu'à
travers les techniques utilisées que
l'on a largement évoqué c'est-à-dire euh
les opérations de Ron ribov c'est-à-dire
du fait qu'à la dernière minute dans un
conteneur va être chargé des
marchandises de la cocaïne pour l'Europe
ou du canadis pour
la pour la zone Caraïbe euh il est bien
évident que cela demande des complicités
locales je crois que pareil en guyen ça
a pu être constaté à l'aéroport donc le
risque au regard des sommes qui sont
proposées à des gens qui faciliteraient
le le passage est relativement important
et les techniques utilisées montrent que
probablement on a ces difficultés là euh
le général parlait à très justement du
contrat de de de sécurité de la
Martinique le niveau de contrôle avec
le les autorités portuaires en
Martinique comme en Guadeloupe comme en
guyan font va remonter le le niveau une
meilleure sécurisation à la fois
périmétrique un contrôle des batch un
peu plus efficace qu'il ne l' qui ne
l'était jusqu'à présent il y a d'énormes
efforts qui sont fait pour limiter ces
difficultés maintenant que ça soit en
externe et peut-être malheureusement en
interne c'est compliqué la réflexion de
la douane sur ce sujet là c'est
qu'effectivement on a identifié les
métiers à risque et que l'on que voilà
et que N laissera pas forcément les les
agents très longtemps en tout cas les
cadres très longtemps sur sur des sur
les mêmes fonctions qui sont
potentiellement exposé et effectivement
de bien vérifier que jamais aucun agent
ne travaille tout seul enfin voilà
essayer de limiter à travers notre
charte desontologique et les contrôles
internes euh le risque potentiel de
prévarication de fonctionnement je
pardonnez-moi je je rebondis parce que
la dernière réunion de haut niveau entre
le gouvernement de saintuie et les
autorités françaises représentées par
Monsieur Jean-Christophe Bouvier préfet
et monsieur Étienne Francis ambassadeur
de France à à castri c'est il y a une
forte demande du Premier ministre de de
saint-uci et qui reconnaît he que à
saintuci fait face à une corruption je
pèse mes mots assez importantes il a eu
une expression de besoin d'un appu appui
de la France à la les aider à lutter
contre la corruption à saint-uci à les
aider à mettre en place un dispositif
inspiré de la France sur la saisie des
des avoirs criminels et pour terminer il
a été décédé depuis un an nous avons des
patrouilles mixes international euh où
nous faisons des patrouilles de
gendarmes qui sont projetés sur les
côtes de saintuci patrouilles à bord des
des bateaux des gardes decôtes de
saintusci et simultanément j'accueille
dans mes unités des policiers de
saint-uci qui patrou sur ma avec ma
brigade nautique donc on a commencé dans
l'esprit CCPD à faire ça depuis un an ça
fonctionne bien et à l'heure où je vous
parle nos partenaires ont peu de moyens
et si mes voisins ont des problèmes j'ai
des problèmes donc moi je projette
régulièrement à l'heure où je vous parle
ce matin j'ai projeté pour 2 jours à la
Dominique un chien
arme euh pour appuyer les perquisitions
pour retrouver les armes qui ont été
dérobées lors de d'un d'un vol commis au
Commissar de police de roseau au mois de
mars j'ai projeté pendant une semaine un
chien stup pour aider aux perquisitions
dans les gangs donc il y a c'est très
nouveau il y a véritablement un gros
besoin d'appui technique de la part de
la France et là nous avons un projet
avec la Direction de la Coopération de
la sécurité de la défense qui relève du
ministère des Affaires étrangères et
européennes euh de les aider à acquérir
les chiens armes billet ils sont
vraiment très très en retard à la
Dominique il y a quasiment rien à
saintuci ils sont moins en retard mais
il se passe beaucoup de beaucoup de
choses voilà ce que je voulais
ajouter effectivement le enfin le le
volet formation par rapport au aux
partenaires voilà permet là aussi de
développer des relations particulières
de confiance permet aussi de de
s'assurer de la de la la fiabilité de de
certains partenaires et pour le le
quotidien des des enquêtes pour ce qui
concerne l'ofast euh on a mis à jour
voilà des des corruptions mais à des
niveaux qui se rapprochent de celles qui
ont été boquées par directeur des
douanes à ubgal euh plus sur des
intervenants portuaires soit directement
à haqua ou parfois euh je dirais dans
qui sont en capacité voilà de de donner
des lieux d'implantation de ctainire ou
d' ou d'en faire
bouger merci beaucoup je crois qu'on
arrive au terme de de l'heure qui nous
est c'est imp parti merci
chaleureusement à tous les quatre et
puis on vous a demandé de d'avoir un une
réponse écrite aussi qui peut peut-être
compléter certains éléments que que vous
nous avez proposé oralement merci merci
beaucoup et puis bah bon courage pour
vos missions
respective mercici excellente journée à
vous égal au revoir au revoir
belle